Well, let's see. We know initial velocity. We know acceleration since we're in the earth.
We can use the same trick to know the velocity if the top of the trajectory is zero
and we're looking for the time--okay.
These were variables correspond to this equation V = V at plus 80
plugging in my velocity at the top is 0 minus your velocity is 20 plus my acceleration
which is - 10 times time.
If I solve this, I find that time equals 2 seconds. That makes tons of sense.
We know the acceleration due to gravity is 10 meters per second per second.
If I start off with the velocity of 20 meters per second going up, I'm going to lose
10 meters per second every second.
So it's going to take 2 seconds for this velocity to go down to 0 and that's the top of my trajectory.